Dr Gears and thanks for continuing this series,
even as atheists appreciate the interaction and the,
uh,
the conversation.
I wanted to ask you something that is both emotional and analytical because
oftentimes you're basically pigged,
um,
uh,
seeing things very analytically.
So you were talking earlier about,
um,
you were talking about the,
the,
the juxtaposition between happiness and,
um,
uh,
honor,
even though I don't think they're mutually exclusive personally,
but if there's a situation,
let's say we're,
someone is truly in love with someone else and they loved them for many years
and decades.
They have a whole history together and then someone,
and then one of the people in this grouping,
um,
start falling in love with someone else.
So it's not that there's less love for the original partner.
How analytically and emotionally do you,
uh,
take care of a situation like that when you feel that you want to stay honorable
and be happy?
Okay.
So the first thing I would say is the devil's always in the details,
right?
So one of the things that I'm not happy about with much modern moral theorizing
is that it takes a story like that,
you know,
and then tries to extract out of general moral principle.
And often that's impossible because the particulars of the situation are very
important.
But having said that,
all right,
so let me think about that for a minute.
I'm not sure that it's possible to be honorable in a situation like that because
I think that you've acted out the violation already and having acted out the
violation to confess it might be the right thing to do,
although perhaps not,
you know,
because if you,
it isn't obvious to me that if you'd be traced someone then you get to have the
right to tell them about it.
I know,
I know.
I know you're not,
I understand that.
Yeah,
yeah,
I understand.
Um,
my observation has been that if there's a tight relationship and if one party
has betrayed by the other in that manner,
that it's almost always irreconcilable.
It breaks it and all right.
You know,
I've,
I've helped people try to struggle through that bolt on both sides of it.
The person who was betrayed and the person who did the betrayal.
Um,
I've seen people grow up and not do it again.
And this was in situations where their partner didn't know.
And in a couple of those situations,
it seemed to me that it might've even been unnecessary learning experience for
the person who did it.
You know,
it,
it helped them develop.
That doesn't mean I'm justifying it,
but life is complicated.
But,
but I think that society works better.
All things considered when you make a promise and you stick to it.
And one of the things I learned from reading young,
which,
which I really liked was [inaudible].
Okay.
No,
he believed that he had his affairs too.
So you might think about it as somewhat hypocritical,
but,
but I think that people can make mistakes without having what they think
necessarily be wrong.
You know,
he said that there were things in a marriage that you can't have unless you're
all in.
And I believe that.
I believe that.
And so if there's a back door open or like to begin with,
or a backdoor opens,
then I think that there's something about the relationship that is lacking at
least,
and I think you pay a big price for that.
So I mean,
it depends on whether you regard a marriage as a practical arrangement or a
spiritual arrangement.
Now really it's both,
you know,
both are important,
but if it's a spiritual arrangement or a psychological arrangement above all,
then I do think that
you don't get the transformation without being all in.
And if you violate it,
then even if you can work it out with your partner,
there's something that you will never get as a consequence.